farther your receivers are talking about
you got a lot more zip on the ball
uh from last year what are you doing
different to increase that velocity
just i got a great trainer that has been
helping me with that
and a lot of it is just practicing
throwing the ball hard
but
if it shows up right now it doesn't
matter it's going to show up in the game
so
i'm looking forward to that besides
your velocity what other
aspects of your game are you trying to
improve upon this off season
knowing
all the answers that i can get to if we
get stuck in a bad play against a bad
defense
knowing the good play against that
defense that i can get to quickly within
the shot clock so
you know that's just comes with reps in
time
[Music]
joe burrow getting ready for season
number two and hey
look it was a it was a very depressing
and unfortunate end of the season for
joe burrow with the knee injury he's
been busting his butt to get back and
ready to go
and chris even with that injury you've
got him
in the top half of your top 40
quarterback countdown yeah coming in at
number 17.
joe burrow a lot of
a lot of projection there yeah as it
relates to health
but we know the talent's undeniable
based on what we saw last year yeah i
mean he's he's a natural at the position
that that's the big thing to me yeah i
mean you know really everything you want
out of a franchise quarterback joe
burrow has in every aspect except for
maybe the thing he just talked about and
let's just start there because he
brought it up i mean yeah that's his
that to me is the big question mark you
heard me say that a little bit last year
if you remember i hope you do you know
that yeah power throws explosive throws
that was the only negative about him
coming out in the draft yeah you want to
throw the ball harder you got to
practice throwing the ball harder you're
going to have to readjust your mechanics
a little bit now what there's a reason i
love the kid i mean he's very self-aware
to make that adjustment he said i saw
him trying to adjust to it last year
during the year but now this is what the
third time in about three weeks we've
heard about explosive you know velocity
that type of talk come out of cincinnati
because he knows that's where his game's
got to go that's his biggest question
mark everything else
i mean reading defenses amazing for a
rookie the fact that they just put it
all on his plate from the get-go hey hey
we're gonna get in five wives put you in
the shotgun yeah it's your first play in
the nfl we had no preseason it's all on
you dissect it throw him surgic surgical
boom boom boom i mean he's amazing that
way and then
he is some slippery sob that's the other
thing too and you know mike i'm i'm big
into that yeah he might be hurt a little
here to start the year might lose this
element but man how many times did you
and i last year look at him and go how
did he get out of that holy cow and i
mean this is amazing right here well a
lot but a lot of times he didn't get out
of it that was the problem he got banged
around and thrown around and he didn't
care
definitely they didn't protect but like
look at this play like actually re chris
thing rewind it can we restart it is
that possible because like i i this is
on but yeah go ahead let's just show it
live and rewind it awesome i mean look
at this he throws that ball a second
before the guy turns around as he's
moving in the pocket i mean he's just
got great feel to go wait i'm going to
throw the ball at this trajectory at
this speed and my guy's not turned
around but i'm gonna put it right in the
spot and the right pace look he turns
around the ball's two feet from him and
is placed perfectly on his shoulder now
movement we know he can do that throws
the ball in the run and he ain't afraid
to throw the ball into some tight
windows you know that's the thing i love
even though he doesn't have the
strongest arm he's got incredible
confidence in his accuracy and his
ability to hit the bullseye and then
it's always this stuff i mean the
unbelievable ability to avoid and keep
the eyes down the field and like we've
talked about a few times with other
quarterbacks right mike he can do it
this is modern day quarterback drop back
look downfield reassess the pressure
look downfield reassess the pressure
here he goes again look at this throw
this is insanity in the membranity are
you kidding me not covered i mean
covered not open running to his right
notices the defender's backs turn so he
could throw a ball over him and it'd be
pretty safe and he puts it on the money
i mean that that's to me where it's just
like i look at the kids sometime and go
he's the natural he's dancing around the
top ten for sure if he doesn't get hurt
with his knee from last year but because
of the knee and all that yeah i knocked
him down i think significantly just
because i don't know where he'll be at
to start the year
the one thing that impresses me when we
watch those one after another the level
of physical exertion that he is showing
to to get himself into a position where
he can make the throw and you're moving
and you're moving and you're straining
and then when it's time to throw the
ball
he puts exactly
the right amount of touch on it right
because i mean usually i mean think
about it if you're straining to do
something and you're going to throw it
you're going to whip it as hard as you
can because everything at that point is
100 plus
to be moving like he was laterally and
to take off
some of that to drop it right into where
it needed to be that that's beautiful
beautiful when you see it one after
another right he just got a great feel
like you're talking about exerting
himself tense oh it's time to throw the
football let me be relaxed and throw it
right and i'm not gonna let the tension
get to me like that right like that it's
amazing he does it he does it as he
moves in the pocket too he'll be just
dancing around you're like man he's
making people miss and somehow oh now
all of a sudden he becomes gumby and he
can throw throw the ball down the middle
of the field nice and relaxed uh he's
got leadership we know that i've heard
from people in cincinnati they say it
he's the leader of the team by like the
third week of the season last year you
know so he does everything he's changed
the aura of the organization i give
value to that you've heard me say that
so he brings some he's got presence on
the field he's got a presence off the
field he's changed our thought of that
organization and
really
does everything
at a high level and as we talk about
with a lot of these guys when he is
healthy what makes him special is when
nothing's there he has the ability to do
what we just saw hey you didn't protect
me hey nobody's open don't worry i'll
still give us a 15-yard completion
that's special so he's taking advantage
of all that's there to be had and then
some
except in that one little area we talked
about at the start
he's got to get better at being a better
20-plus yard thrower of the football to
take advantage of jamar chase and some
of these guys that's the only thing i
look at at his game they just go he gets
better there he's gonna be
you know
big big time superstar top five
quarterback for a long long time
and you said that that he has changed
the perception of the bengals the
bengals are going to need to change in
multiple ways
to ultimately keep him happy long term
and i don't want to look i
hey bengals fans get upset because
before the draft last year
i had suggested right maybe joe burrow
was thinking about making a power play
oh wait you know what
he was folks you don't have to believe
me i don't care but the truth is he was
thinking about making a power play and
as one person explained it to me if he
was from athens georgia not athens ohio
he would have made a power play yeah the
fact that he grew up close to cincinnati
worked to the advantage of the bengals
to get him to not make a power play it
doesn't mean he won't make a power play
and i mentioned that draft earlier who
is the next right the next wave of
quarterbacks to exert their influence
if the bengals don't get joe burrow the
help that he believes he needs he's not
going to take it passively like derek
carr has he's going to exert himself and
maybe that's what the bengals need
maybe they need someone from within
right to grab management by the caller
and say you need to do this you can't
just dog paddle your way through life in
the nfl yeah you're going to make money
you have to try to not make money in the
nfl but you're never going to get close
to a championship if you don't embrace
reality and truly compete with the other
teams out there and hopefully they
accept it when they made joe burrow the
first overall pick in the draft that he
he's going to be that way because i
think he is you know carson palmer was
not that way he just dealt with it until
he couldn't deal with it anymore i think
burrow is going to be actively involved
in trying to get this team to where it
it needs to be and that's good news for
bengals fans if
ownership will go along with it yeah
that's right well he he yeah he doesn't
seem like the like he's not going to sit
quietly he doesn't seem to i don't think
he's not going to make a ruckus but
you're right i i don't think this is a
guy that's scared to like make him
quietly make a ruckus exactly he's not
going to do it publicly he'll do it
behind the scenes that's that's the way
to say it exactly right yeah i think
he'll let it be known so he yeah i think
that that will
be on the horizon for the bengals to
know that pressure's there and lis i
think he's like he's good enough and
what we saw at lsu and that year and
last year to where
i think everybody just knows how
talented he is and everything like that
to where that perception along with it i
think is gonna get pressure on the
bengals to go like wait you got a
special guy here like you you just gotta
give him pieces and this could work and
everybody knows that so that's where the
bengals i think even though they might
not be in their you know nature to do
some of that they might have to push the
chips a little bit more into the middle
of the table than usual because yeah
everybody's watching what you're doing
with a quarterback that we all know and
feel is pretty damn good and could be
real good in this league for a long time
you know you look at what they did this
offseason to improve the offensive line
they went with his former teammate jamar
chase with the fifth overall pick
instead of penne sewell who was right
there yeah if they wanted him left
tackle
um
i i
i would not be surprised
to know that burrow not completely
thrilled with the overall effort i mean
they signed riley reef no disrespect
intended but that isn't a huge upgrade
to your offensive line and i know they
used some later draft picks second round
or on an offensive line but yeah they
could have had sewell
when he when he gave a pre-draft
assessment of jamar chase and you know
he didn't stand on the table like kyle
murray did last year trying to get cd
lamb i think that that burrow
understands he needs to have protection
so he doesn't take those hits because
you know even though we showed clips of
him avoiding the hit he took the hit he
was fearless and he's still going to be
fearless even post acl i believe there's
only one way this guy knows how to play
and it's going to potentially get him
injured again if he doesn't have better
blocking and i think that is an
imperative for the bengals it was this
year and i'm not sure they did enough do
you think they did enough and there's
only so much you can do in one off
season yeah but i just i i wonder
whether they did enough to make it
significantly better for him in 2020
well yeah i you know i i do think so to
to a degree yes i mean it was a tough
decision there i picked number five yeah
penny sewell
some people thought he was really really
special others thought maybe he was the
second or third best tackle in the draft
so it depends maybe the bengals thought
he was kind of more that the guy they
drafted in the second round has
superstar talent i do think they've done
enough yeah i do i mean and when i look
at it yeah riley reef i know you're not
gonna write letters home to mom and be
like oh my gosh mom we changed our team
around riley riley reef's here but still
a serviceable starting offense alignment
got guys like quentin spain and got some
other guys that have been heard or
unproven a little bit that are coming up
the ranks that are just going to have to
start showing up and playing ball and
being better that way you know but like
you look at that graphic right and if we
can bring up that pressure
statistic thing again too
you see here like under pressure is not
that bad with percentage under pressure
but where i would say it's misleading is
the fact that they had to play a style
of football
that was in the shotgun spread offense
and he had to get the ball out of his
hands quickly because they knew they
couldn't block up some of the down the
field throws and some of the things that
needed to be done to protect the
quarterback for a long time so that's
where you know that could be a little
bit misleading and it certainly has to
get better but they they they obviously
know that's a huge point and you got joe
mixon like we need to be better up front
and like that steelers mentality to he's
too good to not be able to run the
football that way so i guess sorry to
blabber here but i think they've done
enough but you're making a good point
despite the and despite the statistics
as to the amount of time he was under
pressure the guy showed a level of
fearlessness that bordered on
recklessness yes made us all nervous and
that the the irony of the hit that
ultimately ended his season
he was
just throwing the ball yeah quick throw
around trying to driving crazy trying to
get rid of the football and they caved
in his left knee as he was delivering
the ball but he he he he played with a
rough and tumble style he'd run the ball
he would embrace contact all the things
we say don't do
he would do
and it's thrilling to watch until the
guy can't get up
and that that's that's the concern and
that's part of what he needs to now
again i think as you develop and mature
you start to get away from that but for
now yeah he's got that competitive
mindset that won't let him do it and
he's gonna have to figure out how to
temper it maybe that's what the acl
injury will allow him to begin to do
very good points kirk cousins coming in
number 16. oh baby that's right
brother
oh kellen is number 16. oh no
i'm sorry sorry cousins comes in at
number 16.
uh
okay well look i can't remember where
you had him last year where'd you have
them like maybe a little higher than
that i think it was a few spots like few
spots higher so yeah there's been some
guys that have jumped him uh definitely
guys that played a little bit better hey
kirk cousins there's a lot to like hey
he gets disrespected a lot we know that
um but man you know when you do go back
and watch him you realize gosh he makes
a lot of really great throws aggressive
down the field throws that you go that's
pretty pretty high degree of difficulty
too they're not dink and dunk and doing
those things he's an awesome awesome
processor of information you know a lot
like we talked about with joe burrow but
except this is a guy that's been around
the nfl for a long time i mean i think
you know enough to where when you see
kirk cousins and he comes up he can read
a defense and [ __ ] that arm back and
throw the football as quick as anybody
in the game and he is aggressive as far
as his mindset and looking for plays and
everything like that you know um
but
i think the reason he's 16 and no higher
than that
goes back to a theme that
i hate to say it we've talked about it a
few times already
and you've said it a ton
the lack of mobility the inability to
make anything happen off schedule is
just less than for this day and age in
the nfl at the quarterback position
it is i'm sorry i don't mean to be a
jerk there's a lot of good things he
does that way but the reason i can't put
him higher than that is because of some
of these clips you're seeing right here
i mean there's just can be nothing can
be done in some of these situations and
hey listen some of them are no-win
situations but as we've talked about a
lot in this day and age if you can't
throw in the pocket off different arm
angles which he's not the best at from
that and because he kind of has a longer
delivery he's not the greatest with
people around him in tight quarters and
things and then to your point when he
gets out of the pocket and does that
it's very few
he can't exactly he can't
it's two steps in mud and someone pulls
him down from behind it's gotten to the
point where he doesn't even try that
much anymore he just accepts the plays
over and hits the deck or
throws the ball away but well i remember
when we did this list last year we we we
agreed that there there are two types of
quarterbacks and for the most part if
you want to be in the upper echelon or
upper echelons as the case may be
you got to be able
to make chicken salad on the fly yeah
when the play that's called falls apart
patrick mahomes prime example russell
wilson as well aaron rodgers josh allen
guys that yeah guys that can move
and guys that can improvise and guys
that can save the coach's ass when the
play that was called bumps up against
the defense that shuts it down cousins
can't do that everything's got to be
perfect for cousins to to perform at a
high level the minute it falls apart
it's done and and that that that
that's a pretty big flaw and that's why
they went after kell and monda that's
why they wanted justin fields they want
a guy just like just like kyle shanahan
wants a guy
who can
run the play that's called and when it
does go to hell
come up with something else yeah well
that's exactly right because you know
even guys like kyle shanahan who go man
my offense is awesome it's the best in
football i need a guy like that in 2021
nfl i can't have a guy that just sits
there like the statue of liberty in the
pocket all the time you know that yeah
it is the the the bar of mobility has
changed
you know the standards of it in the nfl
over the last five to six years there
just is with all the diversity in the
defenses how athletic the defense ends
and d tackles are the linebackers
everything like that you got to be able
to do some things off the schedule off
schedule now listen you put him on a
good team with a great offense and
everything he
he'll take advantage of everything
that's there to be had he'll make all
the right reads oh that guy's open 25
yards downfield that guy's open deep
down field that's great but
he at the same time also if you were on
that great team and had a bunch of
injuries and you know the coach
you know lost his way calling plays yeah
you know to everything you've said he's
not the kind of guy that's going to
cover your ass when it comes to that
type of stuff so in some ways you know i
look at him always go i think he's
underappreciated i mean in a lot of ways
but at the same time
because of what's expected of this
modern day quarterback a little bit he
is kind of the guy that people are
always going to go yeah he's good but
i think we can do a little bit better
maybe and just find somebody with a
little bit of a stronger arm and better
mobility and that's what cousins has to
fight through and he has to fight
through it extra when you're always
asking for guaranteed contracts and
playing hardball money then you get that
perception of like wait we're paying you
like you're the biggest superstar ever
you need to play like that and that's
why i think it also
you know goes into the negativity with
him sometimes here's what it comes down
to yeah
do you want to make the playoffs
or do you want to make it to the super
bowl
if you want to make the playoffs
cousins is your guy
if you want to make the super bowl
and this is based on three years of him
with the vikings
five years before that was it five or
was it six
it was six years six i think yeah you're
right with washington before that now he
didn't become the starter until 20 14 15
ish but
i i
look nice guy
great thrower of the football play goes
well everything's fine but you're going
to get
bounced
before you get
to the super bowl unless you have that
team like you're talking about like like
here listen to this comment and just
think if you agree with me here
if kirk cousins was on the 49ers two
years ago they would have won the super
bowl and beat that they would have won
the super bowl because he would have
made that throw to emmanuel that's what
i mean like it was there he'll do that
right right yeah but he's not gonna be
if we you know put him on the chiefs in
that situation he was down by 10. no the
game is over and you're gonna lose by 20
points you know right so that i guess
that's what we're saying there you know
and it is it's a fine line and uh that's
kind of the issue with kirk cousins
there's some love me and there's some
love me not
but but it all has to go just right yes
and and hey hey hey
dalvin cook
justin jefferson adam thielen irv smith
yeah i don't know what their offensive
line is going to be defense better we
talked yesterday about how this notion
of actually having home field advantage
via crowd noise that will help the
defense that gives the defense another
kick in the pants
the this is
the high-end analytics even number of
years they don't go to the playoffs odd
number year they do but you know maybe
they can make some noise this year we've
talked in the past about how there's not
a murderer's role on the nfc side of the
ledger afc yes
nfc
other than the buccaneers
yeah there isn't like a team that stands
out as oh my god now if the 49ers stay
healthy yes if the packers can figure
this out with aaron rodgers yes but
there's there's an opening there there
is but you know we saw the vikings go
down to tampa last year and they tried
to hang with them early but it was clear
that they were operating on a different
plane than the buccaneers and that was
the first of what would become eight
straight wins for tampa bay taking care
of minnesota coming out of the buy and
off they went so there's a gap there
and
they they they wanted justin fields they
got kel and mau and they're trying to
close that gap with the kind of
quarterback that that you correctly
assess teams need nowadays a guy who can
move
when the walls begin to close in yeah
definitely and you know i i think your
point with the vikings is an interesting
one you know because you're right i mean
listen all about the defense in a lot of
ways to what we're talking about there
you know and if if they can continue to
run the ball like they do with dalvin
cook
and protect a little bit better in the
drop back pass game which has really
been their biggest issue in the drop
back pass game protection the last few
years
there's a chance i mean the offense the
offense should be
you know one of the better offenses in
football with like everything that you
just explained those running backs the
two-headed monster there those two
receivers tight end you know pretty good
run blocking offensive line hopefully
it's better of the past blocking but man
denial hunter kendrick's bar they're
back healthy you're you're young
secondary out there they play better i
don't think it's crazy to think that you
know they could be a pain in the butt in
the nfc and and certainly you know let
themselves be known a little bit
and and remember we get so caught up in
what happened with the pandemic and the
17 games there's that extra playoff
berth that's permanent which makes it
easier to get to the postseason than
it's ever been seven per conference
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports